the headline reads Congress wakes to two
speakers of the house in a country which
already has two men claiming the
presidency Venezuelans are
understandably confused and frustrated
as the saying goes we are left as if we
were lost in space on Sunday National
Guardsmen prevented opposition majority
leader Huang by law and other deputies
from entering Parliament to initiate the
year's session as the Constitution
stipulates in his place the
pro-government minority swore in a
speaker a deputy recently expelled from
his opposition party that wasn't the end
of it this is the headquarters of the
opposition newspaper El Nacional whose
auditorium was used on Sunday night by
the opposition to elect and swear in
Huang why door but in a few hours why
though will attempt to return to the
real Congress building accompanied by
some 100 opposition deputies to
challenge the man whom he says is
usurping his rightful place ironically
Lewis Parra continues to insist that
he's a legitimate government opponent
this is a parliament that continues to
raise the flag of democracy this is an
opposition that represents an
alternative to those in power
but given that he was chosen by the
government that's a hard sell there are
traitors they are corrupt and there's
only one National Assembly the other
vote was a cruel assault on Congress
with the complicity of the dictatorship
Washington has rushed to reconfirm its
support of Y though we are looking at
additional sanctions personal sanctions
economic sanctions that we think will
bring more pressure yet on the reading
McQuade law has clearly lost momentum
and support since he declared himself
interim president a year ago promising
to usher in regime change how this
latest chapter and the power struggle
plays out is anyone's guess Lucia Newman
al-jazeera
Caracas